sprechen wir darüber mit sarah kulka
märz live zugeschaltet von rücker dass
sie jetzt ein erstaunliches vorgehen
dass die polizei ihnen rät sich aktiv
auf instagram in den sozialen netzwerken
gegen diesen zocker zu wehren ihn direkt
anzusprechen haben die behörden keine
anderen instrumente als dieses um sie
und ihre familie zu schützen
doch natürlich gibt es noch andere
instrumente und ich muss an erster
stelle der polizeitaucher vom ganzen
herzen danken
und hallo ich höre sie alles gut also
super ich habe mich ich habe mich gehört
genau ich muss an dieser stelle der
polizeitaucher danken und sie sind total
dahinter seit langem schon ist es ja
nicht nur seit gestern so seit sechs
monaten ungefähr ist es so seit drei
monaten sehr aktiv und die helfen mir so
gut es geht den sind aber allerdings die
hände gebunden aufgrund der
staatsanwaltschaft und ja
es gibt noch andere optionen und das ist
dann tatsächlich wegziehen neue
identität annehmen
in hartz4 reinzufallen dann ins
frauenhaus zu gehen aber das möchte ich
nicht also bleibt mir nur noch die
option eine kampfansage zu machen und
mich nicht ängstlich zu zeigen denn das
letzte mal als ich mich mit einer
kampfansage an die presse gewendet habe
hatte er angst und ist erst mal
zurückgewichen und ich hoffe jetzt auch
einfach das so ein bisschen der druck
auf die staatsanwaltschaft größer wird
das jetzt endlich mal was machen und
richterliche beschlüsse freigeben und
natürlich auch dass dieser mensch
dahinter seinem handy angst bekommt nun
wird vermutet dass dieser mensch ja in
ihrem umkreis zu finden ist
sprechen sie ein bisschen über das
gefühl diesen menschen gegenüber was
löst das bei ihnen aus zu wissen okay
der ist mir schon mal näher gekommen
was mich an dieser ganzen sache stört
dass ich weiß vielleicht das ja aus
meiner nähe kommt und nicht direkt weiß
woher kommt obwohl es vielleicht wissen
könnte ich würde den wirklich gerne
mittlerweile persönlich begegnen ich
habe sehr lange in angst gelebt wirklich
sehr lange
mittlerweile ist bei mir jetzt sind die
emotionen über geschwankt in der gewisse
grundaggressivität denn er hat ja auch
bewusst meiner familie gedroht sonst
waren es immer nur drogen an mich die
habe ich abgeschlossen aber mittlerweile
ist es so dass es an meine familie geht
und da kommen die löwen in mir durch und
ich würde dir wirklich sehr sehr gerne
begegnen
aber ich weiß es noch nicht ob er es ist
und vielleicht ist das auch gar nicht
vielleicht ist er gar nicht aus taucha
er hat mir geschrieben mal er ist aus
nrw
aber ich als die polizei mir diese
lichtbilder gezeigt hat habe ich einen
mann davon erkannt und dachte er es mir
erst vor kurzem begegnet und es mir auch
besonders aufgefallen ob er es ist ich
weiß es nicht
volker ganz viel kraft und energie
wünschen wir ihnen in diesem kampf gegen
diesen menschen und wir hoffen alle dass
die staatsanwaltschaft ja da ein
bisschen sich mehr bemüht und die
polizei ausstattet mit den
entsprechenden befugnissen dort aktiv zu
werden auch in den sozialen netzwerken
und digital ganz herzlichen dank und
tanke ich kraft mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dir
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren